foreign
father
counselors ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the meeting at the council
before we formally start a meeting I
invite my chaplain
father Malarkey of Saint John Henry
Newman Parish to lead us in prayer
thank you Father
you're having me I thought I just have a
quotation from Pope Francis sequence of
quotation aimed at priests and Bishops
but it could be aiming you politicians
as well so I'll give you share it with
you
a politician is one who seeks to walk in
front a monk and behind the people
in front to point out to them something
of the way ahead
among them to feel with the people
and behind to assist the strugglers
and so let us pray
Heavenly Father we ask you to send your
grace upon these our chosen elected
officials
show them the path that they must walk
so that they may guide us ahead and lead
us to where we're meant to be
and we ask this through Christ Our Lord
amen
foreign
apologies I've received apologies for
absence from councilor Coggins Maitland
Paul and z
can I ask if anybody else is aware of
any other apologies please
counselor Carter and Carter thank you
anybody else yes I'm not sure whether
you just said it's actually what
councilor Coggins yeah
thank you
okay thank you
voting and broadcasting information we
continue with a hybrid system in the
chamber this evening for microphones and
streaming the microphone works by
pressing the bar on and off and I will
ask for a show of hands should have all
be necessary this evening
this meeting is also being streamed live
on the council's committee meeting
YouTube channel
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded
except for there's confidential or
exempt items and this activity promotes
Democratic engagement in accordance with
section 100a
nine of the Local Government Act 1972.
thank you
before we proceed with the business
you will already have noticed that we
have a full agenda
as a reminder to you all we're required
to terminate the meeting at 9 30 prompt
and any agenda business has not been
dealt with at this point must be
deferred
in the event of this happening we are
required to reconvene afford a full
council meeting urgently in order to
conclude all the business
I've already set out in an email to you
all explaining the measures
and I will be I'll be taking to manage
this evening's agenda in particular all
agenda items will be subject to strict
timing which means that I will be
limiting the time of speak speeches from
the outset of the meeting
in response to my email I can advise
that the green party group has kindly
agreed to defer their motion regarding
the climate and ecology bill has set out
at eight
brackets G until the next meeting
the first item is minutes and I moved at
the minutes of the annual meeting
held on the 24th of May 2023 be taken as
read and signed as a correct record
is that seconded seconded
all in favor
item two announcements does the leader
of the council wish to make any brief
announcements this evening
no thank you Matt thank you
does the chairs of scrutiny committees
have anything to announce on behalf of
their committee and can I ask you to
limit your announcements to a minute
each please
thank you councilor thank you mayor I
will be brief it's just to let everyone
know that I think many members do know
that scrutiny held an extraordinary
meeting last week to discuss the GM fire
service plans to change sale fire
station from a a whole time model on the
night shift to an on-call fire fighter
model
so we invited greater Manchester fire
chief to our meeting and also invited
the fbu representatives and following
the presentation and members questions
the scrutiny committee members had a
separate meeting to discuss the members
views on what was presented to it by the
fire chief and fire Union
Representatives as a result of members
discussions which we did have a quite a
long discussion the the committee
unanimously rejected the proposals
across party lines as it was strongly
felt the plans presented to us would
increase the risk of danger to the
people of sail area particularly those
living in Carrington
can you wrap up please thank you I will
finish now so thank you very much mayor
Council report
thank you madam mate we not had our
first meeting yet next week next
Wednesday so hopefully we'll be able to
report at the next meeting thank you
thank you
thank you mayor just to say that we have
now completed a piece of task and
finished work on cams and that will be
going to the um full Committee of the
children's scrutiny next week thank you
four questions from the business meeting
which I have been which has been listed
on the council website for members of
the public to view
on the basis that I have asked for the
response to be circulated to all
councilors and published on the website
I will take both the question and
responses read and move on to the
supplementary in each case
the time allocated for supplementary
questions and answers were restricted to
one minute each and all supplementary
questions are to be put unanswered
without discussion
we will now take the questions in order
that they have been received
the first question was submitted by
Council Eckersley
Council actually has had response to
this question and concerning the
management of the Bee parking service
contractor therefore do you have a
supplementary question please cancel
recklessly uh yes madam there
um thank you for providing the expected
service levels within the lease between
traffic Council and Bev
however I do not see any provision our
performance measurements for Bev to
satisfy in relation to customer service
or app maintenance
be the other three star rating on the
Apple Store and 2.2 star rating on the
Android App Store
there have been complaints around errors
glitches the app being in quotes
frustrating for our daily use garbage
and another user saying they gave up on
the app along with the up running slow
not having sufficient measures in place
to monitor performance check Bev against
important metrics including custom
satisfaction in the performance of the
app we'll run the risk of making the
electric vehicle charging points devoid
a value to local residents
do the Council of Provisions in place
around maintaining acceptable service
level standards with Bev as I have just
mentioned thank you thank you
question two is the first of three
questions from councilor Holden
okay sorry Council Williams you may
respond to the supplementary question
sorry councilor Williams thank you
chairman thank you
for your supplementary question
um you'll be aware councilor records the
Bev doesn't only operate in traffic so
it's difficult for me to
um comment on remarks that have been
given as Anonymous feedback
um in terms of uh the the comments that
we've heard from you what I will do
though is I'm very happily receive an
email if you could provide me with a
link to those comments go away discuss
it with officers and I'll get you a
written response thank you counselor
thank you councilor Williams
question two is the first of three
questions from councilor Holden
councilman Holden has had a response to
his first question on annual weed
spraying do you have a supplementary
question please Council Holden
I do Madame mayor first can I say thank
you for the response the written
response it doesn't quite answer the
question that I asked but it'll do for
time being
as far as a supplementary is concerned
over the spring period
extensive linear Wildflower Meadows have
developed along the gutters and curb
stones in my world
with diverse flying plants and even a
small wheat crop in some areas
you see the council's intention to
protect these Meadows during the
spraying process or are these simply an
indication of neglect
councilor outside you may respond to
yourself
thank you for your supplementary
question Council Holden
these are Wildfire medals that the
council's promoting then they should be
protected in that sense of it obviously
but we don't use glyphosate on green
spaces anymore as you will be aware of
generally that's obviously patching
green spaces but where they brought the
highway there are many examples such as
tree pits and other places like that and
working with the uh we spend company
what we actually do they are well aware
where these locations should be however
if you have concerns about some please
do feed them to myself and I'll make
sure they get to the relevant officers
thank you thank you
Madame point of order I'm afraid that
the element of sarcasm within my
supplementary question was just
completely ignored I'm not talking about
spaces I'm talking about gutters curb
Stones the places where every other
local Authority seems to be able to
clear them we have now established these
Wildlife areas thank you
foreign
second question on a number of school
appealers made by parents not offering
their choice of schools can I ask
councilor Holden if you have any
supplementary question please
yes Madam mayor I do I'd like to again
thank the
executive member sorry the spokesperson
for the response and my supplementary is
as follows the lead member will be aware
that 40 of those appeals will Lodge by
parents trying to obtain places at
National mersey School
in line with recent years these parents
have been told that they could have
places in Partington
which members will be aware is distant
and Ill served by public transport from
the areas of Man Award where these
families live
aren't there any plans in place to avoid
the regular use of broad Oak for
children in Man Award or some
enhancement the transport facilities
available
or do we simply not care anymore
thank you councilor Holden to lead the
council Ross in the absence of councilor
Carter May respond to the supplementary
question
thank you mayor um
in terms of the the discussions you'll
be aware that we have discussed with
schools secondary schools about the
placements in the sale area and we'll
continue to have those discussions and
look at options
um I'm particularly proud I was in
Partington early today and I was
particularly proud to hear about how
people speak very highly of broad Oaks
school so I I you know I think you
should reflect on what you've just said
around broadoak because I don't think
it's very fair on the school itself
um but no we'll go away and we'll come
back with with some information about
the work that we continue to do working
with local secondary schools in the sale
area to look at adequate School
placements thank you Matt
another point of order at no point in my
question or supplementary question did I
criticize broad Oak School or the
provision of Education that it provides
my question and my criticism is its use
as a distant outstation for my ward not
the quality of the school thank you
just a moment please
councilor Holden I think you've had an
answer to your question but if you're
not entirely satisfied with that if you
if you have a question to ask councilor
outside outside amazing please do so
thank you counselor Holden
thank you
question four was the third question
from councilor Holden councilor Holden
has also had a response to his third
question about the quality of Roads
resurfacing do you have a supplementary
question Council Holden please
since my allowances were increased I
thought I'd be a bit more productive
um the supplementary we're funds and
time are limited it's long been
recommended that the job is done once
and done right
in specific terms
in specific streets in Man of wood the
quality and effectiveness of work is
questionable
porosity of the surface dressing is
apparently patchy and the Finish is
rough now I will hold my hand up it is
something like 35 years since I did my
road building training but it just
doesn't look right
can we be reassured that at least some
interest will be shown by officials in
the elected representatives in the
delivery of the quality we need in this
work
thank you
thank you councilor
thank you for your supplementary
questioned Kenneth Holden uh as you'll
notice a surface dressing type work has
been around for a very long time now and
obviously uh it has actually improved
over those years from what it was some
15 20 years ago on the system used by
your Administration uh however if there
are particular locations as you can see
from the reply where whether all the
materials have actually uh it hasn't
worked out properly then it is
guaranteed for 12 months and all such
work is inspected afterwards however if
you'd like to give me specific locations
where you think that the work uh
finished isn't satisfactory according to
the contact them please do let us know
obviously uh side streets and all those
sorts of areas actually done with
service dressing mostly obviously we'd
like to do a lot more with other sort of
monies such as we do principal roles and
others obviously but unfortunately at
highways authorities across the country
have been slashed by your government to
spending on highways have been massively
caught this Authority around it's lost
from 250 million pounds so it's actually
uh when we come to privatized roles
obviously the principal main roads have
to again what we've come however on that
basis we'll do what we've come with
cyborg any problems please come back to
us
hi thank you councilor outside
item fall members of the committee
item four it is advised at the council
is advised the council that councilor
Holden has come
was confirmed as a member of the vice
chair of scrutiny with effect from the
28th of May 2023
on the decision I would like to inform
the Council of changes within the green
party group effectively from the 25th of
July 2023 next week
councilor Jerome is to step down as
group leader and councilor Welton will
take up the position
consequently Council Wilson will be the
group's member on accounts and audit
committee and Council Jerome will
replace him on Planning Development and
control committee
these changes are information are for
information and can be noted please
thank you
item five is the B Network committee
report and the time for speeches will be
limited the proposal will be afforded
two minutes and all other speeches will
be limited to one minute each
I invited executive member for climate
change and Council representative to
introduce the report on gmca's new
transport committee
thank you chair and as indicated in the
summons papers the report circulated to
provide an overview of new governance
and oversight Arrangements in respect to
public transport and transport strategy
across greater Manchester in the
interest of time and given the busy
agenda item at the busy agenda this
evening I will take it as that the
report has been read and understood by
members and move the recommendations
contained in the papers thank you chair
the leader Council Ross II
seconded mayor and reserve the right to
speak sorry thank you
all right
do any members wish to speak on this
report
this one okay thank you
go ahead
thanks Chad after 12 years of the gmca
buses aside transport planning
unfortunately remains fragmented with
policies and outcomes very widely across
the 10 councils the issue is best
symbolized in the new self with Salford
cycling scheme on Trafford road which
ends abruptly as our border if the new B
Network committee can help change that
narrative it's for the good we have to
work together if we're to improve access
to transport and reduce its emissions
and carbon footprint Dame Sarah stories
ambition for a GM wide vision zero
approach to Road fatalities will only
become a reality if there's Collective
action
the separation of scrutiny function is
welcome but will this result in greater
or improved scrutiny given the workload
already on those committee members
compare these scrutiny arrangements with
the London assembly and its transport
committee dedicated to scrutinizing the
work of the London mayor and London
transport with the evolution deepening
is it time for an elected assembly
dedicated to scrutinizing the work of
the mayor and gmca
finally the report does recommend the
formation of a Trafford B Network
Steering group and we would be
interested to hear what form this will
take and who will be included thank you
very much
foreign
thank you I just wanted to respond to a
couple of comments from councilor Welton
there
um clearly there are millions of pounds
going into active travel across greater
Manchester at the moment indeed here in
Trafford as well and there is a paper
going to Executive next week that sets
out further progress on our active
travel
um we a master Council Williams and
myself we work very closely with Dame
Sarah's story we've met her a couple of
times now and we have got a very good
working relationship with James Sarah
story and we are very keen to progress
walking and cycling alternatives to the
car across this Borough
um
I don't think you mentioned this but the
revolution that we're beginning to have
with our buses as part of the B network
is an incredibly exciting and welcome
thing for greater Manchester and this is
one this will be one of the things that
the B Network committee oversees getting
more people onto affordable buses that
join up with the natural link and other
forms of Transport will be a real game
changer for greater Manchester it will
bring us economic growth it will
hopefully cut down on our carbon I think
it's incredibly exciting and I can see
the um the direction of travel we've
been having with this under councilor
Eamon O'Brien from uh from Barry who
leads on this work finally we will bring
back more information on the traffic B
Network in due course
thank you councilor Ross the report has
been moved them secondly can it be
agreed please
thank you
item six is the accounts and audit
committee annual report for 22 2023
again the proposal will be afforded two
minutes and that and the other speeches
will be limited to one minute each
I will invite the chair of the committee
councilor Brotherton to introduce the
report please
thank you mayor members of Fred the
report no doubt I want to waste a lot of
time I'd just like to thank Mark Foster
Graham Bentley and the finance staff for
all the work they put in during the year
and our external Auditors and and last
but not least the members of the
committee who put up with me chairing it
for the last 12 months so uh members
it's just for noting really but I do
command the report to the council thanks
man
thank you councilor
is the report the report has noted is
the report seconded please
second date man thank you
do any counselors wish to speak
Council Council report please yeah thank
you madam mayor
just to say that we were concerned about
the delay in completing the 2122
accounts audit
the reassurance for which you had to put
down to the National issues and it's
just that the audit report will be
looking forward to seeing that at the uh
the next meeting
okay thank you thank you councilor
the report is for information can it be
noted please
thank you
item seven is the year-end corporate
Report on health safety and well-being
The Proposal will be for the two minutes
and all of the speeches will delivered
one minute each I now invite a leader
councilman Ross to introduce the report
please
thank you mayor I am introducing this
report on behalf of councilor Heinz this
evening but having been
overseen health and safety for much of
the last Municipal year with uh with
councilor Slater as well I think it's
appropriate that I present this report
this evening
it's a very detailed report it goes
through a the instance that we had some
of which were very serious the support
that the health and safety team have put
in place to support people and also the
trends with some of the incidents that
have taken place including some deep
dives into understanding why the data
has presented as it did I know you will
have all read the report and kisses
considered the report the one last thing
I'd like to say though mayor is um is
Richard Fontana who helped create this
report he recently won an award at the
greater Manchester Health and Care
Champion Awards which recognized those
working hard to improve health and
well-being so I just wanted to put on
records our appreciation for Richard
having recently won that award and the
work that he does with his team across
the council thank you Matt
thank you councilor Council stator is
the second report
and you have one minute I think you've
met and I'd like to um Echo councilor
Ross's comments on uh thanking the staff
who've put the reports together and just
wanted to bring to your attention
actually the launch of your safety and
well-being health and safety initiative
I think it's a really important point in
there at 2.1.2 so if people can have a
look at that I think that that's
something that we should all be really
proud of because it's talking about our
staff and colleagues being safe from the
start of the day until the end of the
working day so I think that it's a
really important part of the report so
thank you and I formally second it thank
you thank you councilman do any members
wish to speak on the report
the importance is for information can it
be noted please
thank you
at this point in the meeting I propose
to vary the order of business to allow
an urgent item of business to enable the
council to consider report concerning
the council's star procurement
collaboration
you will have received a supplementary
report relating to Star the main report
and will identify the potential Partners
were issued to members as a
supplementary last week
we should be able to determine this
matter in public without naming the
partners but this is currently a
commercially sensitive information and
not for public disclosure
I proposed therefore to conduct the
business in the public without the need
to go into closed session
in the interest of ensuring that we can
form formalize a decision on decision
I'm asking for members to restrict to
all debates to non-confidential content
so that the matter can be debated in
part one of the meeting
if necessary however I may have to move
a resolution to exclude the press and
public to continue the base in private
please do not refer to the proposed
partners by title or otherwise revealed
identity of those Partners during the
debate
should members need to identify the
purposes of new partners please refer to
them as partner five or partner seeks
please can I invite the council
representative on Star committee
councilor Patel to introduce and move
the recommendations
Council Patel you have two minutes and
all other speeches will be limited to
one minute
thank you chair
from its Inception in 2013 our shared
procurement service star has expanded
from the original local authorities of
Stockport Trafford and Rochdale to
include tyneside in 2018. the report
outlines the next evolution of this
service with a proposed expansion to
include two further parties taking this
to a collaboration of six councils our
cross border working arrangements are
set out in an inter Authority agreement
an IAA and the report before the council
tonight sets out how the current
governance Arrangements need to be
dissolved and then re-established and
approved by all the partners to
accommodate those changes this report I
believe sets out a positive case for
Change and expanded staff could do much
more of the positive work it's already
undertaking this would include
delivering social value capture on a
greater and more localized scale
retaining a focus on local spend in smes
expansion of our pilot work in Stockport
which looks to set contractual targets
to reduce carbon emissions
we will secure a full cost recovery from
new partners for related expansion costs
critically a bigger group provides
greater long-term Financial
sustainability for staff
it's a collaborative approach already
taken by star has brought significant
financial and reputational benefits to
the participating authorities and
expansion provides greater spending
power and influence
it's important to note that we've
already been working with these two
local authorities for some months
through service level agreements and
full diligence full due diligence work
has been undertaken some staff from
these new authorities will be joining
our Workforce here in Trafford under two
P Arrangements I understand discussions
with relevant HR staff and trade unions
have been positive just to sum up in a
world where local government has never
been under more financial pressure we
see a future in expanding our
procurement and collaborative power to
provide best value for the residents of
Trafford I would like to thank the Star
team for all their hard work on this
very important project thank you thank
you the leader councilor Ross is the
second Emulsion please you're limited to
one minute second did mayor reserve the
right to speak
thank you do any members we speak on
this report
councilor Jerome please
thanks Jeff we support this new
collaboration and understand the
advantages of procurement from a bigger
spending group the fifth and sixth
partner authorities will help more
effective procurement Arrangement
Arrangements will drive efficiency from
suppliers create collaboration and make
us a bigger buyer as the report says
however the green party's 2018 climate
emergency passed by this Council should
drive all our decision making it is
estimated that 90 of a local authorities
carbon emissions come through contracted
Services we note that sustainability is
a principle of our procurement practice
but this needs to be clear measurable
and an important part of any new
spending group we would like to see our
procurement meet the national Toms
framework 2019 guidance for social value
measurement so we can see beneficial
outcomes for the local economy but we
also want procurement tools to measure
and reduce carbon emissions to set a
pass to Net Zero with a qualitative
carbon calculator and a quality sorry a
quantitative carbon capital later and a
qualitative code of practice
communicated also to suppliers that's
why the green party will be asking
accounts in order to include these
aspects in their work program thanks
chair thank you
councilman Evans
thank you madam mayor I'd just like to
take the opportunity commanding star 10
years it's been fantastic it's been
truly successful the interaction with
local businesses is so easy and so long
may continue and welcome the the
expansion is that really commendment to
Star management thank you thank you
cancer report
thank you madam mayor I just wanted to
follow up by saying that uh it's it's a
great organization from its Inception
and it's been expanding and also helping
local businesses and Regional businesses
promoting them giving them the
opportunity to be able to bid for
services and that's the best we can do
on this the only thing I wanted to ask
was that as it gets bigger if a
successful at a greater level what is
the position where if a council uh got
forbid decides to pull out and what
implications would that happen on the
organization that we expect
thank you counselor
right there that's okay the report has
been moved and secondly can it be agreed
please
thank you
oh sorry can
sorry just just sorry please come back
um to cancel at your own
um carbon reduction and carbon action
plans are already embedded in our
procurement process we're actually
um piloting work quite detailed work in
Stockport on scope three targets of
carbon action plans which is contracted
spend activity so um star is supporting
that piece of work and we'll look to
expand that into our partner
organizations when we worked it through
um
so yes you're right it should be a
consideration and we're just working
through how that operates in terms of an
insistence on that
the impact on small to medium
Enterprises really
um thank you for your supportive
comments counselor but councilor Evans
I've been I've set out the positive case
for expansion I think as we expand we
must almost always remember that our key
original priorities remain the same
that's local spend diversity in the
supply chain securing good employers and
supporting the good the GM good
employment Charter as well as driving
our contracts to bidders who are
committed to our Net Zero targets
thank you Council Patel the report has
been moved in a second can it be agreed
please
thank you
the next item is the emotions this
evening seven motions has been listed
under someone says in order that they
were received and as I mentioned at the
beginning the green party motion
at eight brackets G has been deferred
until the next meeting
the proposals will be given two minutes
and all of the speeches will be limited
to one minute each
I would be invited speakers in respect
of the amendments to combine speeches on
the amendment and the motion each member
wanted to speak will have only one
opportunity to address the chamber
after speeches I will move directly to a
vote on the amendment and then without
further debate to a vote on either the
substantive Morton or the amended motion
when carried
please therefore can we keep our
speeches concise and try to avoid
repetitions of points already made by
other members and hopefully this will
give everyone who wants to an
opportunity to speak it may be necessary
to further limit the time of speeches to
enable us to get through the business in
time
motion 8A
proceeding with this first motion
regarding sail fire station's crew
proposals I have received notice that
councilor Port is to move this place
thank you Madame mayor I'd just like to
give notice in order to be a political
and it's a cross-party more or less a
consensus on this of the chair of
scrutiny said in terms of the scrutiny
committee outcome on that decision so as
as I understand you know there is
cross-party consensus on the position of
how we are in terms of maintaining the
24-hour crewing for the station I just
wanted to change the resolution at the
end that it does
acceptable
and then delete them the the main body
of the motion and keep that resolution
can I ask a show of hands in favor of
consent alternative to requesting please
if I could just read the resolution out
perhaps the uh that will make it easier
yeah
and and that's just to say that the
council resolves to right to the greater
Manchester mayor Andy Burnham to uphold
his commitment not to cut services and
leave residents of sale at risk from
delays to response times restating the
scrutiny committee decision and Trafford
Council as a whole fully rejects gmfr's
proposal to move sail fire station to a
day accruing model
but
hi thank you just want to leave without
any discussion can I have a show of
hands in favor of consenting to
alteration to the requested please
sorry Mayo come in just to clarify
um you are perfectly entitled to alter
your own motion
um what you are required to do is ask
Council for consent to do that without
debate and that's what mayor's doing now
mayor's asking for without any debate
consent for the alteration to be made so
can we have a show of hands in that
respect please
consent is not agreed
you should propose the Motions as
originally drafted
thank you
very much the fire and rescue service
that is proposing to move cell fire
station from a whole time model today's
crewing model which means the crews
would provide an immediate response
during station hours 8 30 to 6 pm and up
to a four minute uh mid delayed response
during on-call hours from 6 to 8 30 a.m
gmfras claims that this proposal would
save 340 000 pounds per year and allow
them to invest in other priority areas
Seattle Fire Station has low incident
levels and with the third lowest number
of nighttime life risk accidents and the
third lowest total incidents at night
time in the last three years
however cell fire station is
strategically placed to cover a central
area of the Trafford Borough and
extending to urmston flixton and
Partington
Seattle Fire Station also serves as a
backup for other fire stations in
Trafford and neighboring Brothers in
case of emergencies or major part
incidents
the average response time in sale would
increase by one minute 10 seconds from 7
minutes 45 seconds to 8 minutes 55
seconds and the over response time
across Trafford Borough would increase
by 20 seconds from 7 Minutes 43 seconds
to eight minutes three seconds if the
proposal is implemented
the ongoing changes to highways to
reduce speed limits and accommodate
cyclists will add to response times we
should not be infracted in these
increased response times could have
serious consequences for public safety
especially for vulnerable groups such as
elderly people children people with
disabilities or people living in
high-rise buildings
we will leave the proposal to move sail
fire station to a day cream model is a
buyer's preferred option consultation
that has failed to take into
consideration the residents of
Partington conservative see this as an
unacceptable basing the proposals on
data from the past three covered years
in case
incomparable with any other years
The Proposal offers little or no data on
the Assumption of being able to attend
the station from the fighters home
within four minutes or how this was will
be monitored the consultation does not
do enough ensure that most protected
have they say sales residents and
business deserve better
Council reports
right thank you
I'm not to finish this up
yeah
the The Proposal offers
can we just can we just finish please
right okay so resolve that the
conservative group of Trafford Council
therefore asked the labor Administration
to write can I ask you to please finish
thank you I think your time as well
thank you thank you councilor chocolate
it's a second emotion please
thank you
mayor could I just draw your attention
to the fact that sales central has got
four residential and Care Homes and
which are catered to by the sale fire
station a delay of one minute 10 seconds
especially in winter months when there
would be delayed due to defrosting of
the car or assembling of the crew who
can't we will have to self-transport to
the fire station could make an entire
difference between life and death there
are elderly and vulnerable people in the
Care Homes Athen Manus has got 40.
Fairmont Lodge has got 20. there are
various other residential homes in a
mile radius from the sale fire station a
delay or further delays would cause they
put their life at risk thank you
thank you Council Council I have
received notice of three amendments to
this morning I'm back Council Ernest to
rule the First Amendment and you have
two minutes please
thank you chair this is an important
issue and our Amendment seeks to bring
the motion up to speed with the
decisions scrutiny committee took last
week it was clear in that meeting that
this Council must send the strongest
possible message in response to these
day Korean proposals every party every
councilor must reject these cuts to sell
fire station in full and there are
questions here for the greater
Manchester mayor as well because he put
taxes up in January to avoid Frontline
service Cuts but Andy Burnham has been
nowhere on this and it is his
responsibility we'll turn into our
responsibilities as councilors liberal
Democrats have spent much of the last
few weeks speaking with fire Crews
themselves the strength of feeling
against these proposals is enormous we
are incredibly well served in this
Borough by passionate committed
professionals and this amendment speaks
some way to their experience it's the
crews themselves who tell us that the
modeling on response times is flawed
that response that modeling time is
based on the assumption that staff
responding to out of hours calls can
travel at Blue Light speeds to reach the
station this is wrong and it undermines
the Integrity of the entire proposal and
indeed of the consultation which itself
was poorly implemented no attempt has
been made according to my knowledge
Madam mayor to correct this modeling
despite Crews continually raising this
issue and so we should be clear we're
not muddying the waters we talk about
moving resources around these are
Frontline service Cuts we're not calling
for a pause while we kick the can down
the road residents and fire Crews
deserve clarity now we don't need to
wait for other more considered proposals
to be brought forward to know that the
loss of 24-hour status at sale is
Unthinkable that's why scrutiny
committee was right to take the view it
took last week and fully reject to the
decree model for sale support the
amendment
thank you
Council fast will the Second Amendment
come to First please thank you mayor
many of us in this chamber were in the
fires scrutiny meeting last week some of
the technical words in that report
raised a few eyebrows but I think we all
agreed that the language we use matters
so I'm really glad we've gone with an
out and out rejection and not just a
pause or delay anything else wouldn't
really reflect the views of the
firefighters who put themselves on the
line or the public whose anger was born
of actual genuine concern
at the committee I asked for an example
of another fire station in an urban
setting like sale which has been
switched to day crew only and the
officer admitted there isn't really a
comparable case study anywhere in
Greater Manchester
now we all know there's a raft of
amendments to this emotion all of them
share the same goal of reflecting the
important work of the committee last
week obviously I'd hope that our
amendments accepted but either way I
think we can be confident that the final
motion will be a more Collegiate
reflection of this council's view so I'm
seconding the amendment thank you thank
you
First Amendment only any speakers for
the First Amendment
yes
councilor Evans
just just to stress this is not my
contribution to the debate we're happy
to accept the liberal Democrat Amendment
sorry the first amendment has been moved
and second I invite speakers in respect
of the first amendment's only please
um
right
questions to speak to the First
Amendment
okay Amendment First Amendment nope okay
okay thank you
yes yeah sorry go ahead councilor
thank you madam mayor just just really
uh making a few points to um
just make perhaps remind councilors with
a bit of background to this and if we
look back at a few short years and we
get the origins of this sort of control
of the fire services and I'm referring
to the dismantling of the Fire Authority
and then the neutering of the subsequent
fire committee
At The Mention Of Fire committee
councilors providing all party scrutiny
uh mayor Burnham didn't actually throw
his hands up in horror but he might as
well have done but he made sure that
only the unelected deputy mayor had a
role going forward
that's in my view where Madame has led
to this state of affairs with
inappropriate proposals getting too
close to implementation and convinced
that an all-party Council of our
committee would have seen off such a
half-baked scheme much earlier in this
process thank you thank you
comes about you have one minute to reply
to
the First Amendment yeah
Council report
the show
go ahead
okay Council of order you have you have
one minute to reply
I've already said that we would accept
the uh
um liberal Amendment on this
so there's nothing further to say on
that
um
sorry
right sorry Council Ennis I think sorry
it was your turn to reply sorry for your
file
foreign
thank you chair uh we'll quite happy to
proceed to a vote
thank you can I just ask
about the procedure because there's
another Mo there's another
um amendment to to the motion and
shouldn't that be actually raised now
before the vote
yeah please
just to clarify where we have one more
more than one Amendment we deal with one
Amendment at a time so at the moment
we're asking you to speak to that
Amendment
and then we take a vote and then
um that will either amend the emotion or
not we move on to the second amendment
and so forth on the final Amendment or
on those items where you've only got one
Amendment mayor will invite you to talk
to the amendment and to the motion at
the same time as well so she'll make
that clear when she reads that out is
that okay that makes sense
thank you is that all right Doug
thank you
thank you congratulations
right I will
I will now put the First Amendment to
the vote can I have a show of hands and
keep your hands raised while the records
have been taken please
oh
that's all those in favor sorry all
those against
thank you any abstentions
no
the first amendment is lost thank you
I now invite councilor Baba to move the
Second Amendment you have two minutes
counselor so
man
um
I'm not clear whether now is the point
or after it's been proposed can we allow
it to
and seconded
thank you mayor and with apologies um
with your how come the chamber's
permission and after a discussion with
the green group we'd like to propose a
further addition to the labor Amendment
and that is to add a paragraph from the
green group Amendment paragraph one
which starts Following over a decade of
austerity introduced by the conservative
government and also including the final
paragraph of the green group Amendment
which starts Trafford councilors support
the response sent by Trafford scrutiny
committee to the greater Manchester fire
and rescue consultation so we are
seeking permission from the chamber to
include those two paragraphs in the
labor Amendment
without any discussion can I have a show
of hands in favor of consenting to do
alterations as requested please
thank you
sorry consent is agreed you may propose
the motion and explain the alterations
you wish to make thank you
thank you chair
could I just start by saying that you
know we share the same sentiment about
the day growing of the sale fire station
um we as vote counselors as well as the
residents are very concerned about the
proposal but we also have to look at you
know what has been done so far not just
the talk and blame game we
we are aware and you know want to bring
this to attention of you know others who
are not aware that the consultation
period has been extended there have been
two meetings our councilors have
attended those meetings we have you know
also got involved with the community and
encourage them to take part in that you
know surveys online surveys in addition
to that
could I also take this opportunity and
welcome and you know commend our leader
who has written to the chief of the you
know fire Services Rescue Services uh
you know voicing our concerns uh also
could I also you know take the
opportunity and you know not to kind of
remind everybody what has been happening
in the past 10 years you know the the
conservative government which has cut 20
million pounds you know from the fire
Services as well so you know that that's
the effect on it in addition to that we
also you know were informed that
scrutiny meeting has also discussed this
issue so we we welcome and could I
propose the amendment to the motion you
know as shared thank you thank you
councilor councilor Williams is the
second
to Second the amendment please
thank you Chad I'm grateful for the
opportunity to Second the labor group's
amendment to this motion regarding the
proposed changes to Staffing provision
at sale fire station I welcome and Echo
the remarks already made by my colleague
councilor Bubba about the impact the
proposed changes will have in sale
however I would add that what is not
reflected in the Tory groups motion is
that the most Stark impact are the
proposed changes will be felt in
Partington having already met with
firefighters stationed at sale along
with their fbu rep I was pleased a
fortnight ago to attend a community
consultation event held at Partington
Community Center along with my
colleagues Council of heights and Andrew
Western MP during the meeting the Chief
Fire officer and assistant chief I have
officer confirmed to us when we asked
that the proposed changes to Staffing
provision at sale fire station will
result in parting to receiving the
slowest blue light response time to a
nighttime 999 call of any locality in
Greater Manchester
residents at the consultation rightly
highlighted that Partington is a
uniquely isolated Community serviced by
poor transport routes there is
essentially just one road into and one
road out of the area the significant
concern is that OnePlus the Chief Fire
officer had no response to investing in
highlighting any volume of evidence that
shows a clear association between risk
of and from fire in neighborhoods with
higher levels of deprivation
understanding that is extremely
concerning that GM FRS proposed a model
that would worsen response times to 999
calls in Partington given the areas
contains some of the most acute
deprivation thank you in Greater
Manchester thank you chair
the second and the second amendment has
been moved and seconded I invite
speakers in respect of the Second
Amendment only thank you point forward
um
our constitution section 13.4 reads an
amendment to emotion must be relevant to
the motion and will either be to refer
them out to the appropriate body or
individual consideration to leave
outwards to leave outwards and insert
words into insert words or AdWords so
long as the effect of it is not to
negate the motion our motion is calling
for action it's calling to write to Andy
Burnham the resolution of our motion is
very very clear
the resolution of the amendment
is just empty it asks us ask the council
to do nothing so if that doesn't negate
the original motion I don't know what
does so under Section 13.4 I think the
amendment should just be rejected by the
man thank you
councilor Evans can we just pause please
want to consider you that thank you
my view is that the proposed amendment
does not negate the motion given the
definition of the word itself the
amendment can be considered
just a question as the green as a green
Amendment been withdrawn and are we now
speaking to the what will become the new
substantive motion or are we going to
hear thee and then for the Green motion
after this as Council of us has merged
potentially merge the two
comes
thank you Matt I mean I'm happy for to
for the green group to confirm this but
yes
um this would become the substantive
motion if voted on this evening but are
happy for the green group to confirm
that
yeah thanks Joe we did speak with
councilor Ross early earlier and we felt
our amendments were very similar
um and so they agreed to put insert two
paragraphs from our Amendment into
theirs we think this is a good
um undertaking and we're happy to
support the labor Amendment and withdraw
the green party Amendment at the same
time
thank you councilor
the second amendment has been moved and
seconded I invite speakers in respect of
the Second Amendment only please
yeah not a man
I don't think anybody heard what you
said I I certainly I think agnis
understood what you've said there so
could you explain where we are in the
procedure please
[Music]
can you repeat that councilor Evans
please we didn't quite catch it
could you explain where we are in the
procedure please
go ahead
okay sorry just to clarify we have heard
the First Amendment the Second Amendment
labor Amendment incorporates the green
Amendment and so the third and final
amendment has been withdrawn technically
so this is the only amendment to the
motion so what I would invite I'm sure
what the mayor would invite you to do is
to speak to both emotion and the
amendment at this point this is your
only point to speak after that she'll
move straight to a vote on the amendment
and then a vote on the substantive
motive motion okay
I thank you can we have speak soon
please thank you
foreign
okay
um
I've got councilor Jerome Leicester
Williams Evans and Hartley do we have
any other speakers please
oh councilor Thomas as well sorry yep
anybody else
cancer acting
anybody else that's it yeah thank you
can we start please
thank you chair
um
the fire service review is actually
quite a serious piece of work and I feel
people have jumped too easily to dismiss
their deep data to dismiss their
expertise and just dismiss their
findings about the redistribution of the
service to meet the greatest need but
obviously at scrutiny it was highlighted
that the problems with the Partington
blue light service which I think are
real and that's why I believe our
Amendment and the labor Amendment are
really causing for a pause where we can
review this and speak to the fire
service again about how we go forward
and we have to be sensible about this
and I just feel the lib dams and the
conservatives I've turned this slightly
into a political football
needlessly and the conservative motion
uh talking about cyclists and active
travel infrastructure is absolutely
wrong that infrastructure is well
thought through and put together in a
really sensible way and it does take
things like the fire service into
account when it's put into place and I
just feel that it's it's awful that
they've done that and we also fill the
lib Dems have played that game slightly
too can we wrap up we will be supporting
this amendment
and counselor Evans please thank you
thank you Madame mayor and I'd like to
acknowledge counselor Williams
Association at the Carrington and
partying will probably uh by these
changes suffer at the worst at the
furthest away from South fire station so
I would like to acknowledge that and if
we have admitted that out of the
original motion I apologize our thoughts
are over there as well
um we would have accepted the liberal
Democrats amendment to our motion which
came in after the scrutiny meeting and
back to everything we proposed and
recognizes as we all know he's who is
actually responsible for Fire and Rescue
Services in Greater Manchester the mayor
Andy Burnham I'll read unedited from the
gmca website the mayor of Greater
Manchester Andy Bernan has
responsibilities around the governance
and budgets relating to Greater
Manchester police and greater Manchester
fire and Rescue Services
that's why we pay him a precept every
year to fund the fire service
this is a mayor who managed to get our
Police Service into special measures and
is now moving on to our fire service the
mayor who can waste 48 million on
cameras which aren't needed and the
mayor who commits all 10 borrowers for
up to 300 million to fund his vanity bus
franchise scheme the mayor sets the
precinct thank you for the fire and
rescue the mayor is responsible for fire
and rescue I cannot believe we're
arguing about not writing to him thank
you thank you
um counselor Thomas please
thank you mayor just the reason I
support this amendment is it clearly
states in the amendment that we've
already sent a letter by the security
committee to the fire and Rescue
Services therefore the conservative
motion is out of date
way out of date and to bring in things
like the calzone and we know that
Council Evans likes to whittle on about
is absolutely missing the point thank
you
thank you councilor
councilor Leicester please
thank you chair
um the green group fully support the
local fire service and Rescue Services
and it is really clear that the whole
chamber seems to share the same
sentiment and all want to support them I
think we're just finding a different
wording but we have had over a decade of
austerity and that's the attacks on
Frontline services and we're seeing the
results of this now with the fire and
rescue service
we feel that but however we feel that
the current proposals do not
sufficiently take into account the
impact of more remote communities such
as Partington Warburton Dunham and
Carrington and it also doesn't consider
the High Risk Industries in Carrington
we agree that using the data from the
last three years is not representative
calculations need to be based on current
and future risk levels taking into
account the return to car usage and all
also large social events
um we'd also argue that having
firefighters on call within four minutes
of sales station is not practicable we
support we support the letter that was
sent to the head of the of the grace
Manchester fire and rescue Service as a
result of the extra extra scrutiny
meeting and with inquiries Council to
support this amendment
thank you
Council Acton please
yeah thank you mayor I think
we're getting ourselves in a mess really
here tonight because quite frankly we're
all unanimously against the plans that
are being put forward and I think yes
that there are added words from all of
the political parties here and we've got
to try to unite in terms of of how we
actually move forward and the way that
we move forward is to make our
representations to the fire service you
know in good faith that we do not agree
with their proposals it will it will
actually take a long time
um you know a lot a larger time quite
frankly to get an emergency vehicle to
Partington and I think that would be a
tragic mistake and I think that's where
the risk lies and we cannot ignore
austerity and Overlook that thank you
because that is probably some of the
basis for the actual action that has
been taken thank you councilman
counselor Hartley please
uh thank you Matt these proposals are
obviously causing residents some
concerns and I've made clear that I'm
opposed to them it's very easy to point
the finger at the mayor of Greater
Manchester as the original motion does
and as the liberal Democrat Amendment
did as well actually but we should be
clear in this motion about what has led
to fire service tough to make these
difficult decisions
councilor Evans mentioned the precepts
but what he admitted to mention is that
it's not the precept alone that funds
the fire service so in a similar way to
Local Government funding central
government Baseline funding for the fire
service has been cut by 40 since 2010.
in 2010 we had 1800 firefighters we now
have a little over a thousand in 2010 we
had 66 fire engines in Greater
Manchester we know 50. we used to have
two fire engines in sale two in
Altrincham and we now have one each so
of course we're opposed to these
proposals but we need to remember that
cuts have consequences this is the
environment created by Tori esterity
driven by Tory's eel and enabled by the
liberal Democrats Public Services hold
out to the bare minimum with little room
for movement so of course we should
opposed to the sale well let's be clear
about what's that is to this point thank
you very much
you have a one minute right to apply
should you wish to do so
thank you
as
as then heard you know widely
[Music]
um
our you know proposed amendment
clarifies you know our position as
stated you know we welcome you know the
leader has written to uh the fire
Services Chief uh the security committee
has discussed this issue well in detail
um as rightly said by my fellow
colleagues we cannot ignore the
austerity and the reason behind you know
that you know we have to face this
proposed day growing proposal we all
share the same sentiment and you know
I'm sure that we could all agree to this
amendment thank you
thank you councilor
I will now put the Second Amendment to
the vote and can have a show of hands
please and keep your hands raised while
the records have been taken all those in
favor
thank you all those against
any abstentions
the Second Amendment is now carried
thank you
since we've had already had a
substantive discussion I propose without
any further debate to move the vote onto
the substantive notion
I will now put the substance abortion to
the vote and can I have a show of hands
please so keep your hands raised while
the record's been taken all those in
favor
thank you all those against
any abstentions
the substantive motion is carried thank
you
the next motion this evening is about
the impact of voter ID laws and
democracy and is to be moved by Council
frass please
thank you mayor
the introduction of voter ID by the
conservatives was an attempt at voter
suppression plain and simple and it
worked people in our Borough lost their
right to vote due to these trumpian
tactics is easy to dismiss the
relatively small percentages but as
liberals our job here is to defend not a
class not a block not a group but the
individual and as local leaders we all
need to stand up for our residents
Democratic rights by targeting the help
to get those voting certificates where
they're needed most
and limit some of the damage from this
assault on democracy
on Election Day One voter told me how
angry they were that his 18 year old
grandson possessed neither passport nor
driving license so couldn't vote a
blatant attempt to rig the system he
said why are older persons bus passes
allowed but a Young Person's bus pass is
not
I can only speculate
back on the campaign Trail at seven
o'clock the heavens opened so I dashed
up to the first house with a front porch
where I met yet another victim of the
elections act 2022
a recently divorced woman answered the
door aware it was polling day check
passport check decree nisi nope you see
her passport with a married name doesn't
match her entry on the Electoral roll so
whilst all the men in the house dashed
off to vote prompted by my arrival on
their doorstep welcome or otherwise this
woman could not vote without an
additional layer of bureaucracy to prove
who she was so I'm going to end now by
thinking about the choice of words used
by the Prime Minister when attempting to
defend this Mr sunak said I think that
voting is a privilege and we have a set
of rules in place etc etc
definition of privilege a benefit
restricted to a particular group of
people Beyond most no voting is not a
privilege voting is a basic right
thank you
is councilor gosh to Second emotion
please I'm seconding can I reserve the
right please Mr Smith thank you
I received a notice of an amendment to
the motion and I invite councilor
Harding to move this new please
thank you mayor
um thank you councilor frast for
bringing this motion this evening
um the amendment has been circulated
prior to the meeting and I hope that
you're able to accept the amendment in
the spirits in which it was intended
really because I think we are generally
supportive of the spirit in which you
bring this motion and we support quite a
lot of the the words that you you use
but I just wanted to clarify really that
it was the end paragraph where you talk
about the Council on transparency which
sort of indicated that the council would
potentially not be transparent and
that's not the case at all because we
were legally allowed to only release
certain amounts of data all um all
counselors were issued prior to polling
day the monitoring officer released the
data which we were allowed released
guidance of what we were allowed to
release on the day things have since
changed since polling day and just as as
the final paragraph of the Amendment
states that going forward there
shouldn't really be any reason why we
can't obviously subject to any future
legislation but if you're happy to
accept the amendment in that spirit it's
basically saying that yes we support
what you're saying it's about what data
we can now release but we should be able
to by polling District let you know be
able to see exactly what's happened the
references you've made about disparities
and around different Wars whether it
disproportionately affects Women Voters
all of those things of course it's
really important that as a council and
as counselors we're able to see that so
we can Target interventions more
appropriately and support our residents
so as you rightly say have access to
vote so I put the amendment to you in
the spirit that were generally supported
with your emotion but it was just some
of the wording that I'm afraid we
couldn't agree to there thank you
thank you councilor
I understand that counselor Hart is the
secondary about the amendment please
uh thank you Matt not much to add to
what councilor Harding has already said
really we shouldn't speculate about the
precise impact that these measures have
had on Trafford residents uh it's pretty
clear that they will cause some
disenfranchisement I'm sure about that
and councilor for us set out well the
way in which that disenfranchisement
would likely to be discriminating
against people with certain protected
characteristics but we should await the
report from the Electoral commission and
the data that's published and I suppose
that last motion this one seems to aim
its higher in the wrong direction it's
not an issue of the council not being
transparent about this
um as councilor Harding made clear that
you know the data to be collected from
the polling station and the data that is
published is a matter that's been
strictly controlled by the government so
with that I'm happy to move the
amendment thank you thank you councilor
the amendment has been moved and
seconded I invite speakers in respective
amendments to combine speeches on the
amendment and the motion each member
wanting to speak will only have one
opportunity to address the chamber after
these features I will move directly to
the vote on the amendment and then
without further debate a vote on the
motion
thank you
can we have
oh
hello I write the speakers I've got at
the moment is councilor Evans Council
new gosh
and counselor
Spencer
and councilor board is that that
everybody
thank you
counselor
so uh
myself councilor Sutton okay apologies
confusion over the seating perhaps this
evening right okay
thank you councilor certainly missed her
please thank you
thank you mayor um green group uh fully
supportive this motion uh and the spirit
the the the purpose behind it uh we
spent Poland day uh visiting uh
Parliament station's Crosshair Awards
speaking to staff and certainly in my
case I didn't find a single member of
Staff who'd had to turn anybody away
clearly that was not the case across
Trafford or across the country
um and we're also uh supportive of this
amendment which
echoing the reasons already given is
clarifying the the legal situation uh
relating to this data and what the
council can and can was and what it's
not able to do and now can or cannot do
um thank you
thank you
councilor Evans
thank you Madame there um data released
by Trafford shows that more than 99 of
people brought ID to the polling station
for election it's elections on the 4th
of May
um collated figures across the borough
show 31 965 residents voted 120 polling
stations the data also shows that while
317 people were initially turned away
187 did return with acceptable ID and
were able to vote overall 99.6 of people
who turned up to polling stations were
able to vote overall fantastic job by
our electoral Services personally I had
more complaints about polling cards not
arriving which we have control over than
anything around IDs in fact not single
comment about IDs our group does not
support the directs attacks on the
government we do not accept the
insinuations around favoring one party
or another however we can support the
resolution of this motion and the
amendment because they are sensible so
we will be supporting it although we
reject the pre a lot of the preambles in
both the amendment and the motion thank
you madam thank you councilman Council
new gosh please may I um it's my right
to reply sorry
yeah thank you
thank you Chad I don't think I asked to
speak but um
but as you're inviting me to I might as
well take the opportunity
I just put it to us from the green party
group sang the elections office and the
team and the work that was done by this
Council the communication of our voter
ID to the electorate was I thought
excellent and the figures you know show
The Amazing Word that was done so we
just wanted to say thank you to the
Trafford Council and the amazing
election that they ran thank you
councilor Council report please
I just wanted to quickly say as well you
know that the uh
the Tilt in the way that it's been put
in terms of making it political quote
attempt to tilt the system in their
party's favor uh it's not something I
agree with and also the fact that you
know the the lib Dems do have a pension
for Sometimes using data in ways that uh
uh they can manipulate in a way
um we're talking about four percent of
the people without uh four percent voter
ID actually applied now who how many
people actually applied uh to have their
voter ID and when the four percent uh
was just four percent were successful so
just things like that which don't seem
to fit thank you thank you councilor
Council new gosh please thank you thank
you Mrs mayor uh can I begin by saying
and clarifying we did not intend in any
way to imply a lack of transparency on
behalf of the council
um we wish to bring we estimates clear
though that there is an undeniable link
between deprivation and
disenfranchisement uh we fully intended
that uh
and that was fully intended in the
recently acknowledged in this act when
it was dreamed up by the conservatives
so um I'm certain that many of us
um were approached in those days before
the mayor elections by those that
realized far too late they that they
lacked the now necessary identity papers
to vote
the fact that this disproportionately
hit those whose main day-to-day priority
was putting food on the table and paying
the bills rent and mortgage should not
be edited out of this motion and they
are the top two paragraphs not the
bottom which I pretty much accept
um I wish the council to note that the
vast majority of those disenfranchised
did not attend the polling station so
are not going to be included in any of
these figures thank you thank you
councilor Harding you have a right to
reply
um for the purposes of brevity really I
think I think that I'm reading that the
amendment is being accepted really so I
think I'm happy to move to the vote then
thank you
cancer first you have the right to apply
to the motion thank you thank you
so to reply briefcounsel in the comments
from the conservative group I I
understand there is a partisan element
in in the motion we've submitted about
tilting the voting system in favor of
one party but I was merely quoting the
ex-business secretary Jacob reese-mogg
it when I was doing that it does state
that that comes from the conservative
Minister himself
um and I'd like to mirror some of the
comments my colleague councilman ugrash
made this is not impugning the council
in any way it's merely forward-looking
we'd like to be transparent it wasn't
suggesting we hadn't been this is of
course the first meeting since those
elections where we put motion so it is
not suggesting we haven't been
transparent it's merely setting out that
goal that we should be transparent
um I am concerned and minded to abstain
because of the crossing out of the lack
of inequality the the reference to
inequalities obviously we have got data
at an English level comparing Council to
council to council and we see that
knowlesley as I reference the third most
deprived was the most rejected so I'd
like that to have stayed in so we might
abstain on that thank you thank you
all those in favor
all those against
any abstentions
thank you the amendment is carried thank
you
since we've already had a substantive
discussion I propose without any further
debate to move to the vote on the
substantive motion I'll now put a
substantive motion to the vote and can I
have a show of hands please and keep
your hands raised while the record has
been taken please all those in favor
thank you
for those against
and the abstentions
the substantive motion is carried thank
you
the next motion this evening is about
take tackling damp and mold in Trafford
social housing and is to be moved by
councilor the polary please
thank you mayor
um it's my honor to move this important
motion and I note the labor Amendment
and we as a group will be supporting it
and look forward to working together in
the future for something specifically
for private renters within Trafford
but if you'll allow me I just want to
take you on a short journey in the
minute and a half I have left
in 1985 a young nurse moves 300 miles
with her son with a new job waiting in
the NHS and a now fabled NHS house for
her to move into that house was in the
story State damp and mold apparent
however it was reported and over time
dealt with eventually becoming a safe
warm and secure home
fast forward to 2021
36 years later
36 years later and I was invited into a
property in Trafford to see that not
much had changed since my childhood
mold has taken over bedrooms of children
botched cavity wall insulation and stock
ventilation throughout the property and
a tenant was in despair with the Housing
Association being pushed from Pillar To
Post without a plan or any action to
rectify the issues that they they and
their family were living with
two years later during my own election
campaign this year in 2023 again I enter
a property under rental contract from a
Housing Association and I'm yet again
hit with damp mold bad ventilation and
inadequate Roofing none of this was or
is acceptable regardless of it being 38
years ago or last month
this should be a mark of Shame for all
of us that families and individuals
people who have served our communities
and country are having to live in
anything but clean dry safe homes
I say all of us regardless of political
affiliation
because this is about Trafford residents
not us
this is about Council being held to
their duty of care for these residents
to do nothing and wash our hands of this
issue is not an option
support this motion and let us move
forward together and put the social
Renters of Trafford first thank you
thank you
councilor Ennis the second motion please
thank you Matt I want to start by
acknowledging the scrutiny committee's
work program for the current year I know
the seriousness of this issue is keenly
understood across the chamber if you
come home every day with your kid from
school knowing that you have to sleep
beneath a moldy ceiling at night or
knowing there's nothing you can do about
the blown double glazing or the lack of
cavity wall insulation in their bedroom
that is your whole world it's an
all-consuming worry but far too often
the culture within housing associations
is wrong because if when you go to
report these issues you are met with
indifference and an attitude from some
housing officers that you should be
grateful for what you have is it any
wonder why so often people turn away
from help and towards despair this
motion outlines the powers that we can
and should be using more frequently it
commits us to close working with housing
associations but it leaves them in no
doubt that we are serious about tackling
dampen mold now on the conservative
amendment I have first-hand experience
Dragon housing associations Kicking and
Screaming into offering temporary
accommodation and I won't be alone in
this chamber it's part of our
responsibilities as diligent councilors
but if notorious to put something down
in writing we of course support that so
I'll just finish now social housing is
about offering Pride thank you community
for all and that's what we should keep
in mind thank you when we vote thank you
I have received notice of two amendments
to this motion and vice councilor white
to move the First Amendment you have two
minutes please
thank you chair very happy to move this
amendment glad to say the liberal
Democrat group say this is a friendly
Amendment which it absolutely is and
simply incorporates the actions this
council is already taking to tackle the
issue of damper mold mold and poor
unacceptable housing conditions in both
our social and privately rented sectors
as a council we are absolutely committed
to improving standards and we'll always
take the necessary action if we become
aware of people living in substandard
conditions regardless of the reason for
it
I would just add that he's also really
important to include the private rented
sector in this motion and I'm more than
happy to work with the liberal Democrat
group regarding that going forward as
for two long landlords have got away
with providing accommodation that is
well below standards required alongside
the combined Authority this is something
we will tackle and I would also urge the
conservative group to write to their
Minister for housing and the Secretary
of State for leveling up to confirm the
government's commitments so the renters
Reform Bill which will give private
tenants more rights and more security of
tenure thank you chair thank you
comes to rehearsed as a secondary
Amendment that's the hearse please yes
um I'm second David the issue and dump
have mold in our social housing is
without question something that needs to
be addressed it's Unthinkable that a
two-year-old should die because of the
conditions of their home and yet it
happened three years ago in Rochdale
of course the direct responsibility for
social housing lies with the housing
associations who manage it and as a
council they're supporting residents
with advice and monitoring reports of
dump and mold but this is a much bigger
issue than holding social housing
providers to account last year Energy
prices tripled for many people meaning
residents could not take the advice of
heating and ventilating their homes to
avoid dump and mold government in action
meant that for too many the choice was
between Heating and eating and families
have to feed their children
as our Amendment states this is not just
an issue for social housing three times
as prior three times as many private
rented properties have dampened mold and
I've spoken to tenants faced with
eviction for simply bringing this to
their landlord's attention
I'm supporting the amendment we have to
stand up for our residents right to live
in safe and comfortable housing but we
are limited while the government
continues to ignore the housing and
energy crises and it is time the
government took bold steps
the first amendment has been moved and
seconded I invite speakers to respect of
the First Amendment
only please
no
councilor Perry you have one minute to
reply please
happy to move to a vote ma'am
I will put the first Amendment to the
vote please and can I have a show of
hands to keep hands raised while the
record is being taken
while those in favor sorry yeah
thank you all those against
any abstentions
the first amendment has been carried
and I'm about to counselor Duncan to
move the Second Amendment you have two
minutes
yes thank you madam mayor I'm proposing
an amendment to the um to the motion
I'd like to propose an amendment
um to the published
papers seeking advice from Council
officers I need to change the word from
compelled to expect
thank you very much for highlighting
this issue this motion however I don't
think it's gone far enough
one once a landlord is made aware of
dumper mold issues they should be
expected to provide alternative
accommodation whilst works are being
undertaken where there is a threat to
health
members will no doubt be aware
I indeed highlighted such issues to this
Council on the 21st on the 25th of
January 23.
we're the leader of the council
confirmed I raised very important points
so what has been done since that date
please
so of course I do it everybody
to um to vote for this and we want to
work with cross party on these serious
issues as agreed thank you
thank you is there a second to please
I think that uh we are getting to the
point where we're all going to violently
agree on this topic and uh I think the
sooner we vote in favor the better but
thank you
thank you the second amendment has been
moved and seconded I invite speakers in
respect of the amendments to combine
speeches on the Second Amendment and the
motion each members wanted to speak will
have only one opportunity to address the
chamber after these speeches I will move
directly to a vote on the amendment and
then without further debate a vote under
substantive motion
difference
right I have councilor Ross councilor
Evans he's a cancer nugosh
yes
anybody else
sorry I would just
Council certain is a
no
matter Spencer thank you councilor
um Council Ross please thank you Matt
just to confirm that we are content with
the labor amendment that we have just
voted for so we'll be sticking with
supporting that Amendment and we will
not be supporting a further conservative
Amendment thank you
thank you
councilor Evans please
that's a shame councilor Ross but either
way it would be pleased to support the
motion we'd be pleased to support the
labor Amendment I'm so sorry that you
feel unable to expect uh housing
associations to re-house their tenants
when their houses are uninhabitable
however
um housing this should be a Simple
Solution this isn't a money issue within
housing associations they're running
developments all over and registered
providers it's a management issue and we
should be able to force a tissue with
them so I I commend the work the
council's done I commend both motion and
Amendment and I'll appeal again please
why would we not want
um people with uninhabitable damp homes
to be re-housed while they're repaired I
can't believe that thank you
thank you Council new gosh please
thank you Mr Smith
um
I note the amendment in the labor
Amendment here I just want to point out
that though we are already leading I I
have I have residents here that reported
damp and mold in their house in every
single room of the house on almost every
surface reported first of April 2023
Target date for fixing this 31st of
March 2024 we have more to do thank you
councilor Spencer please
thank you chair
um we support the motion we support any
efforts to highlight the huge problem of
damper mold within the bora's house in
stock as well as the devastating health
effects it can have on anyone who has to
live with it Although our two biggest
social housing providers have recently
adopted strict guidelines to deal with
this we know that far too many people in
Trafford are still living in a polling
conditions
we also want to highlight the problem of
damp and mold within trafford's private
rented accommodation the effects of
which are felt just as widely as that as
social housing but with even less
regulation I'm sure the majority of us
here would agree that both aspects of
this problem arise from a continued lack
of Regulation the rental sector where an
estimate 20 live in such conditions has
a worthily inadequate funding system
this means that poorly funded councils
are left there in the brunt and using
limited resources to try to address the
issue of damper mold better funding from
the government is needed to be able to
properly inspect and manage damp moldy
homes and regulate it because nobody
should be forced to live like this in
thank you councilor councilor Roy please
thank you chair just briefly uh just to
cancel any grocery's point more than
happy to take those cases up with our
enforcement team if you send them across
to me that's absolutely no promise all
and just to cancel everyone's point in
relation to what local authorities can
do what would be really helpful is if
the government gave us a piece of
legislation that actually enabled us to
do everything that we want to do because
at the moment The Regulators social
housing is a pretty toothless tiger so
maybe if we write to the government and
ask them about that that might be a good
idea thank you
thank you
cancer acting please
yeah I think I think all of us actually
agree that you know tackling this issue
is probably a number one priority for
you know particularly in the way that
you know many many people are living in
these damp moldy conditions and it's
just just all wrong and and I think
um that we we did discuss uh this last
week in in scrutiny and we prioritized a
piece of work around this where we'll
invite the housing social housing Chiefs
and discuss what they're actually doing
and and how are they going to
deal with all those houses that have
damp and have have the mold
and I think
all of us really together should unite
across the political party to get this
so thank you Council thank you
counciloratory you have one minute to
reply if you wish to do so
hi I just wanted to thank the chamber
for the mature way in which we've
discussed this this evening
um I'm well aware of the health
implications councilor Spencer and well
aware of fire risk to most these houses
on top of the problems that these
residents are already living in and and
I'm sure the residents in my own Ward as
well as in many of yours will be very
grateful for the mature way in which
we've discussed this so thank you very
much
thank you very much
I now put the Second Amendment to the
vote and can I have a show of hands
please and keep your hands raised while
the record has been taken all those in
favor
all those against
any abstentions
thank you
the second amendment has been lost thank
you
since we have already had a substantial
discussion I propose without any further
debate to move to the vote on the
substance of motion
and I will put a substantive motion to
the vote and can I have a show of hands
and keep your hands raised while the
record has been taken all those in favor
Elders against
any abstentions
the substantive motion is carried thank
you
members may I just remind you about the
time and the rules about finishing at 9
30. we still have three motions to deal
with so far so can you keep your
speeches concise to allow us to complete
the business tonight without the need to
reconvene at another date
the next motion concerns leasehold and
rejuvenate Rejuvenation of come and hold
and you will be aware of the
conservative group has proposed an
amendment which I understand in the
interest of time is to be accepted
therefore I invite councilor Harding to
move the motion as alternative please
thank you mayor
firstly
um
can I pay tribute to some of the
tenacity of some of the residents that I
have been supporting around this issue
supporting them with not much effect it
saddens me to say really
I have walked around the Eden Square
development with residents who in all
good faith purchased their properties
that were meant to be in a premium Town
Center location
I have witnessed the leaking roof the
broken fire doors the damage to the
walls the shodia repair work I've met
with residents over several years now it
really has been going on that long as
they struggled to get any clear
communication and no Clarity on huge
hikes in service charges and little or
no response when it comes to getting
repairs completed but it isn't only the
fire doors that are broken the whole
rotten system of leasehold is broken
residents who are working hard and
watching their hard-earned money just
frankly disappear in a sea of endless
chain charges people who feel they have
no control at all over where they live
leaseholders report a range of problems
including High service charges
escalating ground rents and lack of
transparency over these charges it
really is an absolute Minefield what
I've been trying to work with them on
freeholders who block attempts by
leaseholders to take control over the
running of their buildings excessive
admin charges and charges for
applications to extend lease agreements
and a lack of knowledge over their
rights and obligations we've known for
years that the system is broken but the
reforms that people have been crying out
for just haven't happened the governor
the government government themselves
admitted there was a need for Urgent
reform as far back as 2017 and in
January this year they pledged to scrap
this system
this government is presiding over what
is now commonly referred to as fleece
hold
ministers must act now they must keep
their promises to leaseholders by ending
this outdated system and deliver long
overdue Justice to Millions it is not
right that homeowners are being punished
by these centuries-old rules thank you
for hurting Council rights
second emotion please thank you thank
you more than happy to secularist motion
I'll be I'll be quick we have now been
promised reform to this area for over
six years it is simply unacceptable that
this practice is allowed to continue
this government is allowing insecurity
anxiety and understandable anger to
Fester over something that could be
stopped immediately for new homeowners
and reformed in the interests of the
residents of leasehold properties there
is simply no excuse for this situation
to continue and for people who live in
leasehold accommodation to continue to
live in a Perpetual state of anxiety and
uncertainty about their most important
possession of their home thank you chair
thank you councilman right does the
council consented abortion as altered
sorry is that with the amendment is a
minute already yeah
just one minute
the motion has been moved and seconded
do any members wishing to speak on the
motion each member wanting to speak will
only have one opportunity to address the
chamber after these speeches I will move
to vote on the motion
councilor Evans
anybody else
okay killer Evans thank you madam mayor
I'm presuming that our amendment has
been engrossed into the original motion
which is fine I'm very happy to support
the labor motion this has to stop it is
outrageous people buy a house they want
to own a house they don't want somebody
else owning it and telling them what to
do so we are very happy to support it
and I'm very happy to support a letter
to the minister thank you
all the Jewish speak
thank you chair the um the green party
also supports this this motion and um I
just wanted to thank councilor Harding
for bringing the motion and speaking
about the they're so precisely about the
impact it has on people and their lives
um the green party have also pledged
support to this change
um and and we've said you know we want
to abolish the leash old in favor of
common hold it's a system that's used
widely in other countries already and we
should democratize ownership and allow
people to make joint decisions about
what should happen in shared areas of
flats and housing complexes
um the legislation has already been
going since 2021 and phase one I think
has gone through the house but the
government is stalling on the phase two
the important part and I think everybody
would agree that this government just
needs to hurry up and get it done
because this is affecting far too many
people and the impacts already severe
thank you chair thank you very much
councilor Hardy is the right to reply
um I think just move directly to the
vote mayor I'm happy with all the
responses and thank you for the cross
party support this evening thank you
I will now put the motion to the vote
can I have a show of hands please and
keep your hands raised while the
record's been taken all those in favor
all those against
any abstentions
the motion is carried thank you
members may I just remind you about the
time and the rules about finish eat 9
30. there's two more motions
to deal with so we're keeping speeches
please concise and allow us to complete
the business tonight
we have now completed the items of
business and the time is nearing oh
sorry right so the next motion is about
discharge of raw sewage and to be moved
by councilor win Stanley please
uh thank you mayor I'm proposing this
motion because our quality of life has
been treated with utter contempt it's
been dumped on with raw human sewage
it's been dumped on on an industrial
scale it's been dumped on in the
waterways we walk alongside and our
families go boating and paddling in and
our residents are rightfully very very
angry angry because it's been allowed to
happen at all and with the exact same
companies doing the polluting they're at
the exact same time extracting huge
amounts of dividends and bonuses angry
that the reacts of central government
has for the most part being serious
crisis what sewage crisis how on Earth
did we get into this position well I'll
tell you lack of governance from
Westminster nowhere more evident than
the environment agency who resources
have been slashed since 2010
Environmental Protection funding has
dropped by 80 and enforcement by 40
unsurprisingly prosecutions felt most
800 in 20078 and just 17 in 2021
locally this lack of governance was
brought home to me by an environmental
Professor from
um Manchester University who when we met
on the banks of the mersey reeled off
some truly alarming statistics which we
all assume become an environment agency
or off what but he said not the case at
all the main organization is flagging
the issue our local community groups
Anglers associations or as we have seen
in the Press pop singers and comedians I
repeat a complete lack of governance and
it's symptomatic of the last 13 years
the examples are everywhere it's not
just water we've got trains that don't
work with energy companies run for
shareholder profit while the rest of us
shiver through the winter we have
workers rides being ignored while the
government looks the other way
we need a rebalance in the way water is
governed rebalanced in favor of ordinary
people not shareholders this is why the
motion caused the polluted pays
principle to be firmly established the
industry must pay for its own failures
it also calls the actions needed to stop
this tsunami of series to be meaningful
they must be enforced no more excuses no
more half measures no more looking the
other way thank you man
thank you
thank you so always
just please thank you madam mayor happy
to second
since the conservative government
privatized water in 1991 water companies
have paid a staggering 50 billion pound
in dividends to their shareholders this
country is Awash with Tory government
sanctioned filthy raw sewage
my beautiful ward of Longford has the
river mersey flowing through it I love
these green lungs and use them daily but
the stench and filth deposited by United
utilities is sickening and The Smoking
Gun is flushable whites which decorate
my ward after every such discharge
interesting the water companies are
currently lobbying government to ban
flushable wipes estate sanctioned hiding
residence I guess Tory MPS block changes
that would have ended sewage discharges
and finally held the water companies to
account where they effectively green lit
another 4.8 million discharges up to
2035. by the time I finish speaking
there will have been at least one more
dump of raw sewage into our waterways
instructor and urmston last year there
were 24 sites polluted 1095 sewage dumps
over a period of time amounting to 8.62
months I urge every right thinking
member of this Council regardless of
political Legions I did the right thing
and support this motion
thank you the motion has been moved and
seconded do any members wishing to speak
on this motion each members wanted to
speak will only have one opportunity to
address the chamber after these speeches
I will move to vote on the motion
okay
meters three I think it's right okay
thank you it comes around this please
thank you Madame
um our conservative colleagues in
Parliament myself and colleagues here
are clear that sewage in our Rivers is
unacceptable the government is committed
to tackling storm overflows and
protecting public health and the
environment from discharge sorry to ask
councilor Ennis oh so sorry so sorry
he'll love me again in a minute then
thank you for that Matt I'll be really
quick counselor Evans
um I just want to put a fact out into
the chamber United utilities discharge
raw sewage into English Waters more than
000 times in 2022 and that is why it is
so important that we debate this and
that we pass this motion which builds
nicely on the work that we started last
year when the liberal Democrats moved a
motion on this subject so thank you
councilor manage please
come to men's please thank you
thank you Mrs the liberal Democrat group
are supported for this motion
the lib Dems and Parliament have
constantly held the Tories to account
over pollution of our waterways
so Graham Brady was one of 264 Tory MPS
who voted to allow surgical dumping to
continue
the polluter pays principle is a
commonly accepted practice that those
who pollute should pay to clean it up
when a publicly limited company such as
United utilities needs to raise funds to
invest in their infrastructure to clean
up their mess they should go to their
shareholders and not the bill payers or
the customers
UK water companies paid out 100 1.4
billion rather in dividends last year
alone
rather than repairing what they should
have done the Lawless water industry
must be forced to put up to put the
environment before profits
thank you I hope everybody supports
thank you
councilman Leicester please
thank you mayor the state of the
waterways and coastal areas is
disgraceful in this country and ever
worsening meanwhile the water company
and shareholders continue to be paid
huge dividends we fully support this
motion and support the principle of
pollute pays however as greens we would
go further we need off work to supply
the enforcement order on the companies
so that they carry out their statutory
functions ensuring that water actually
reaches people's houses and sewage
doesn't end up in the watercourses or in
the sea the industry cannot continue to
be rewarded for failure the English
water companies have been handing an
average of 2 billion a year to
shareholders since they were privatized
three decades ago that with the hugely
inflated salaries of the water bosses
should have gone towards plugging the
Lakes
the greens say that we should cut
dividends and ensure that water bosses
are no more than 10 times the salary of
the lowest paid
ultimate ultimately to end League stops
sewage discharges and cut bills we need
to take the water supply back into
public ownership which the green party
believes should be done at the earliest
practical
thank you
just comes from evidence wants to speak
please
yes go ahead
and um
this is the first government to take
steps to address storm overflows in
August 22 the storm overflows discharge
reduction plan was launched back by 56
billion of capital investment which is
the largest infrastructure program in
water company history this includes
massively increasing monitoring at the
frequency and duration of discharges
from approximately seven percent in 2010
when labor left office to 90 now with a
hundred percent by the end of the year
which might explain the figures in
Labor's motion the figures are now at
least being recorded any suggestion that
any MP or Council has voted to legalize
or allow more sewage into our Rivers is
simply not true concern conservances
have only ever voted to strengthen
requirements on water companies with
targets through the environment acts
2021 strengthening the rules on
pollution from Wastewater and
agriculture the motion is simply
opportunistic and baseless and our
conservative group while opposed to
sewage discharge because of the Motions
of x-sections vexatious nature we will
abstain thank you man thank you
councilor Evans comes to instantly you
have a right to apply
ah thank you mayor and thank you to the
lib Dems and greens for supporting this
motion maybe some differences around
policy certainly some similarities in
principle and thank you to councilor
Evans for giving the conservative
group's response but OMG you have
demonstrated yet again to the people of
Trafford you're not listening
pretending things ready in place or
plans already made or the meaningful
fines are being levered on the industry
but you're missing the main point
the Great British public no longer
believe a word that you say they've
watched too many car crash interviews
with story ministers assuring them that
all is well
they've heard the common select
committee's opinion on the honesty yes I
said honesty of the last but two Tory
p.m maybe last four three one loses
track
so conservatives please stop the
rhetoric and do something meaningful go
on better Lobby inmates in Downing
Street get them to call the general
election let the labor party sort out
the mess like we did in 1945 1964 and
1997. thank you thank you
I will now put the motion to a vote can
I have a show of hands please so keep
your hands raised while the record has
been taken please all those in favor
all those against
any abstentions
thank you
the motion is carried
councilor certain please can you move
the next motion proposing a greater
Manchester assembly
cancer sudden please
thank you mayor
um it might not be immediately obvious
but this motion is at heart about
fairness uh fairness to Greater
Manchester fairness to the people the
greater Manchester Noble democracy is
perfect and they should be reviewed and
revised periodically to ensure they
Remain the best fit for their
ever-evolving purpose
Devolution and the role of Maya has
helped reinforce the status of Greater
Manchester as a city region with a
single unique identity the greater power
is now being handed to the mayor warrant
the balance of stronger Democratic
scrutiny it is time to move away from
the opacity of the gmca towards one in
which all voters voices are represented
fairly it is also time for the special
treatment of greater London to end
leveling up if you will
anticipating objections about cost
firstly in the context of national
finances as the motion indicates the
costs are not that large secondly none
of us would have any difficulty
identifying huge financial waste in
Westminster enabled by insufficient
accountability
finally Democratic representation is too
expensive is a very dangerous slippery
slope which I'd urge all members to keep
away from
thank you thank you
councilor Spencer is the second abortion
please thank you yes so second and
reserve the rights reply thank you thank
you
the motion has been moved and seconded
do any members wish to speak on this
motion each member wanted to speak will
only have an opportunity he wants to
address the chamber after these speeches
I will move the vote to the motion
laugh
s
okay thank you
councilor Patel please
thank you could I clarify chair whether
I've got a minute or two minutes
just looking at the time
two minutes yeah
okay thank you
um like our last Council debate on PR I
think there are a few leaps in the
narrative here on this motion I reject
the idea that a directly elected mayor
working with the leadership of elected
members is fundamentally undemocratic
that the majority of those GM leaders
are of a different political party to
the one putting forward this motion is
not an argument that it's
unrepresentative
gmca is fought hard for greater
Devolution of Paris from Westminster
it's noted that opposition parties had
little to say publicly during that time
but wait until that very difficult very
difficult process is concluding to come
forward with the ask for the model to be
changed the Devolution deal is a hugely
complex area of work it will require
significant resources locally to work
through the implications for us in
Trafford as an Administration we are
focused on what that means for us in
areas such as transport Net Zero housing
job skills and culture we see
opportunities and challenges for our
communities where it seems as I see a
political opportunity free from the
responsibilities of making this deal
work on the ground the ask of this
motion is that finite resources across
GM turn away from delivering for
residents to focus on electoral on an
electoral overhaul
I understand that when you lose control
of an urban Council like Brighton and
when mid-suffolk on an anti-housing
campaign you may be pondering how you
achieve more politically under existing
systems that the majority of the GM
authorities and mayoral role are
currently labor-led isn't a quirk of a
flawed system nothing is gifted in
politics and nothing should be taken for
granted
I do acknowledge there is a wider debate
around Regional Devolution but taking
the London model and transporting it
here isn't necessarily the answer I
believe we will see changes in how we
operate at a GM level and that this
Devolution deal is the start of that
journey I cannot however support this
major political overhaul within GM at
this moment in time and not for this
model thank you thank you councilor
Paulie please
the liberal Democrats will be sporting
this motion
um I love a bit of democracy and I love
that everyone has a voice and I love PR
and I hate the fact that the
conservatives have rolled back the pr
elements of our mayoral voting system
um last year in the mayoral Act
second preference votes the preference
votes we should have more of it not less
of it having an assembly in Greater
Manchester is logical with all of our
committees waste transport policy
everything
we should have that body that's elected
on a PR basis enabling us to scrutinize
whoever the mayor is at the time
you know and I'll also add Wales
currently has a population of 3.2
million greater Manchester's is 2.7
why do we get nothing and Wales has a
chamber of 40 60 going up soon and been
made aware
that's what I'm saying thank you very
much thank you
councilman Evans please
thank you Madame and more more
never more than now has scrutiny been
required within GM when we have seen the
gmsf rename places for everyone whether
you support it or not and is rolled on
for the best part of eight years and has
clearly cost Millions want and waste of
Millions on failed and unnecessary
cameras a commitment to improve School
Readiness abandoned even when he
attended this chamber it was a closed
meeting scrutiny has failed for over six
years within GM and now reformed allows
even less time 22 hours in a year to
scrutinize 7 billion of spend there
isn't a conservative counselor in GM and
I dare say a labor lib Dem or green who
isn't just frustrated by the
unaccountability of GM in the mayor with
wanton waste on Bonkers schemes such as
well a cycle route to Sheffield and so
yes we welcome this motion we will
support this motion and anybody should
support more accountability which is
solely lacking within greater Manchester
thank you Madame thank you councilor
councilor accordingly please thank you
Mike I'm on record as long as
long supporting them
how to go to Manchester some sort of
council I've always
I am going to vote against this today
and I don't believe it's
the issue has been ventilated enough yet
um I do see us going there
um with this having said that I do think
there is a democratic deficit and it's
not primarily at the greatest Manchester
level I still believe in we need more
neighborhood demand
I don't know I'm sticking out
believe we need democracy in our
neighborhoods
um but yet I'll be voting against this
and welcome it because it's beginning to
ventilate a subject that means
ventilating
um obviously the whip is important to me
councilor board please
did you wish to speak
thank you Madame I mean
this demonstration of the awful lack of
scrutiny accountability with gmca and
inclusion with Manchester mayor which
has been demonstrated here tonight in
fact
without not wanting the labor group not
wanting to hold the mayor accountable by
writing to him directly on changing the
sale fire station model
so it just goes to show you know there
is a war for lack of scrutiny and
accountability
with the labor situation and we do
thank you
Council Ellis please
thank you may I want to agree actually
with councilor Patel great Manchester
combined Authority has worked the game
powers from London labor would just
prefer to use those powers in the dark
in private without too many questions
being asked please if an assembly is
good enough for London it is good enough
for greater Manchester thank you Matt
thank you councilor councilor ad said
please
thank you
chair just died very briefly uh I think
what does concern me and isn't really
coming out in the motion particularly
was a was really whilst today's
Manchester has that do Evolution uh what
this would actually do is take Powers
away from local authorities like us so
instead of us being able to deal with
things strategically and plan for our
own residence a lot of those have would
be stripped away to a regional resource
something much harder for us local party
be able to take things to Residents and
talk to them consult with them if it's
done on as much wider GM level I think
that things could be lost that much more
we need closer contact I think Council
accordingly said well if you're looking
at things like more things like Airway
servicing and things like something like
that I'm sure we could all support and
that how we communicate with residents
but something like this I think is real
would strip Powers waivers and actually
would leave us expose in transplified
Fair residence thank you
thank you counselor
is anybody else wants to speak
thank you councilor brother too thanks
uh no just a small Point those of us
have been here a long time will remember
there was an elected assembly for
greater Manchester uh and and Mrs
Thatcher and our colleagues are
conservative friends got rid of it so
it's a bit hypocritical of them now to
come and talk about the requirements for
an elected assembly when they got rid of
the thing uh you know about nearly 30
years ago
thank you counselor
cancer certainly you have a right to
reply
um thank you I'd like to very quickly
thank the conservative libland groups
for their support uh with recognition
that Manchester is getting a greater
Manchester getting a raw deal I was
disappointed that the first labor
response Mr represents the motion which
is clear that the resources would come
from central government and instead
played the austerity economics policies
of either or and also showing that
Labor's commitment to real democracy
really does always prove to be way for
thin I just also like to ask councilor
ad said talking about whether
um things should be focused more at the
authority level whether he objects to
the new uh greater Manchester bus set up
and would prefer it to be done at a
local Authority level and Trafford to be
operating its own separate bus Network
thank you
I will now put the motion to the vote
and can I have a show of hands please
and keep your hands raised while the
record has been taken all those in favor
uh so excuse me councilor Spencer has
reserved the right to reply
sorry councilor Spencer deserved the
right to write reply as a seconder sorry
I do beg your pardon sorry yes go ahead
so the north-south divide the level in
up debate it's something that we hear a
lot of and to some people that's all it
is it's a debate and a conversation and
that's it but for those of us that
actually live in the North we see the
effects of these things in almost all
aspects of everyday life that left
behind feeling that comes with being a
resident in a northern town or city will
never be improved if we don't start to
have really difficult conversations
about why it exists and how to make it
better
and if something's good enough for
London why are we denied it as has been
mentioned we're almost the same size in
population as Wales
why did we fight to have an elected
mayor if we denied the accountability
that the mayor in London has some things
are worth paying a price for democracy
is not something that we should do on
the cheap we need to accept that better
politics only comes about with better
accountability and we need to be
prepared to address that thank you thank
you
I now put abortion to the vote can I
have a show of hands please and keep
your hands raised while we take the
record all those in favor
all those against
any abstentions
uh the motion is lost
thank you
as the motion set out in eight brackets
G has been withdrawn that brings us to
the end of the meeting
that then at the end of the meeting I
thank you for your attendance and
extended General invitation to join me
in the power of words for refreshments
thank you everybody and I hope you have
a rest I hope you have enjoy your
evening thank you
foreign